j'accueille d'argence
[Musique]
je pense qu'on peut pas passer mes yeux
est-ce qu'on peut passer enfin tarzan
c'est le nom que lui donnent ses
collègues routier en juillet il était
devenu tout naturellement le chef du
groupe parce qu'il parlait plus fort que
les autres après dix jours sur les
routes il s'était décidé à lever le
siège et ont tous obtenu quelques
concessions sur les conditions de
travail mais les routiers avaient
convenu qu'il n'en resterait pas là avec
le permis à points et qu'il reviendrait
à la charge dès la rentrée aujourd'hui
tarzan a troqué sa casquette et son
t-shirt pour sa plus belle veste après
tout ce n'est pas tous les jours qu'on
ait reçu chez le premier ministre les
revendications sont restés les mêmes
mais le ton a baissé d'un cran quinze
ans a été impressionnée par sa rencontre
il en ressort un optimiste il lui reste
maintenant à faire partager son
enthousiasme à ses collègues
[Musique]
tout le monde en a parlé à retrouver
tarzan
le chauffeur routier qui a paralysé la
france entière retraité il vit
aujourd'hui à saint jean de luz où il
vient de s'installer après un passage
éclair dans le bordelais il y coule des
jours paisibles et loin des
manifestations
[Musique]
c'est là que je vais faire un peu mon
temps parce qu'il n'y a pas beaucoup de
monde et c'est très joli c'est pas une
plage normal il ya des rochers c'est
très beau ça fait penser au maroc
j'aime bien la mère mais j'aime ça
quand tu as travaillé pendant 47 puis
j'ai plus que d'un seul coup tu te
retrouves seul parce que moi je me suis
retrouvé salle j'ai perdu quand j'ai dit
j'ai perdu ma nicole m'accompagner
chaque année il ya onze ans en 2006 et
il ya quatre ans
j'ai purgé plus aucune famille il
fallait que je change maintenant je
regarde la mer combien c'est chez moi
depuis le décès de sa compagne ni et
sans famille il s'est installé dans le
pays basque pour se rapprocher de
quelques amis
la série succès c'est dur faut accepter
des fronts donc c'est pas évident la
preuve est ce que tu veux penser tu vas
pas au dessus vous tu penses par le
travail déjà
et tu penses pour ça rien tu regardes
tu fais ton toujours après être
la solidarité des chauffeurs routiers la
médiatisation de son action lui ont valu
une notoriété qu'il regrette d'avoir
laissé derrière lui
qui vont pas des prix d'ailleurs
des gens là
naturellement ça m'a fait plaisir d'être
super un premier ministre s conçu par
des ministres transport d'avoir fait des
émissions de télé avec même notre
président de la république sarkozy j'ai
fait des visions exarque aussi ça m'a
permis quand j'étais licencié à cause de
ce conflit de rentrer de passer les
concours ventre à l'hôtel de ville et
puis de tous les ordres de jacques
chirac du rideau d'argent n'a plus de 33
tonnes mais par nostalgie de la route il
n'hésite pas à affronter les kilomètres
pour se rendre dans le bar tabac où il
joue régulièrement au loto voilà je vais
faire un loto
bonjour madame se rappelle très bien de
temps avant le routier c'est pour ça
maintenant la 12 points 61 ans et
j'étais le pommier non syndiqués est
reçue pourra parler de l'époque qui
était pierre henri gourgeon
maintenant que tu reviendrais
pas pas un grand loto pour qu'on sablent
le champagne ici pas important
plus que jamais la solitude pèse sur les
épaules de tarzan dont le feu sacré
c'est un petit à petit rongé par la
nostalgie
jal auto plus près mais bon
cru en fait j'ai réagi du temps à perdre
on tu vas me faire gagner un jour
alors
voilà on est chez moi bon alors moi je
jette au rez de chaussée
voilà mon nom ça c'est bon il ya le
derby vais naturellement et à coluche
cas j'adore et collèges donc jouer mais
un chapeau la grande gueule sympathique
sensible et profondément simple symbole
d'une france d'en bas qui a tant plu aux
médias est aujourd'hui oubliée de tous
alors où j'ai pris mon presse bruit sur
la table ah oui
mais son regard s'illumine à nouveau
lorsqu'il parcourt son album souvenir
j'aime bien changer un creux là aussi
des souvenirs de rencontres aussi
improbable qu'exceptionnelle des moments
qui l'ont marqué et qui semble dû
manquer alors les white premier ministre
pierre bérégovoy la photo avec le
premier ministre et ça c'est la sortie
de matignon avec tous les journalistes
qui l'attendait plus leur
alors des cartes des cartes bon ça c'est
mireille dumas tchèque chirac qui
m'avait envoyé ses voeux philippe risoli
et ces jeunes là où il y en avait invité
jarry faire dit philippe bana la cigale
le 26 mai 94
je suis plus heureuse
ça ne fait rien quoi je moi je regrette
pas ce que j'ai fait quoi
ça m'a fait connaître et puis la preuve
que 18 ans après on reparle de moi
ben ça fait plaisir quand vous êtes à la
retraite et puis qu'on reparle de vous
donc vous n'êtes pas tout à fait à la
retraite quoi quand il reste un petit
truc pour la faire tourner autour du
président
et si finalement aujourd'hui tarzan et
c'est le porte-parole tout trouvé des
retraités
marron s
[Musique]
et maintenant la lumière se rallume sur
tarzan
dans bienvenue sur le plateau de parler
vous êtes né en 1948 à paris d'une
famille d'origine modeste vous commencez
à travailler à 14 ans comme cooper
d'abat-jour ckoi cooper de belges c'est
simple vous avez un gabarit et puis vous
mais c'est sa soeur du papier havas jour
bien qu'un couteau ou coupées on se
trouvait bien les doigts enfin voulait à
tout prix faire un métier extérieur
dehors dans la rue au contact des gens
vous devenez coursier en solex
document rentrer leurs vainqueurs du
rythme
et puis manutentionnaires et déménageur
et à 22 ans vous passez tous vos permis
poids lourd c'est le début de votre
aventure de chauffeurs routiers
absolument en 92 vous avez 44 ans vous
roulez depuis 25 ans vous vivez à
ménilmontant ménilmuche dans un
appartement de 20 mètres carrés serait
avec nicole c'est vrai dit ni oui c'est
vrai qu'ils décident et montrent leurs
seins alors vous votre pseudo c'est cet
argent ça bientôt bon c'est un collègue
qui m'a baptisé tard dont vous aviez le
look le loupe oui j'avais les cheveux
longs dans st c'est là que le
gouvernement d'edith cresson décide
d'instaurer le permis à points donc six
points pour tout le monde voilà pour les
conducteurs lambda comme les
professionnels ça nous plaisait pas
marrer les premiers à s'opposer à ça
c'est vous intéresser les routiers 1
voilà gouvernement ne veut pas reculer
sur ce principe et quand bérégovoy
remplace edith cresson ça change pas à
faire chaud du tout et ça ça empire sur
les routes c'est le bordel blocage du
trafic opération escargot pneus brûlés à
l'été 92 le mouvement se durcit
brutalement donc avec le blocage de
dépôts pétroliers de gennevilliers qui
est le point stratégique en fait
d'approvisionnement de
carburant pour l'île de france voilà
alors là vous est à la manoeuvre oui
c'est bien joué avec brio de
castagnettes louis vuitton n'est pas
considéré on a des horaires dingue en
outre 62 heures par semaine et est
finalement cette histoire du permis à
points c'est un petit peu la goutte
d'eau qui a fait déborder le vase quoi
bah oui parce que de toute façon il
était toujours en infraction alors que
ce soit dans les matières dangereuses ou
ce soit dans les dents le dans les
autres matières de transport
on accélérait ont été pris par le temps
tout ça donc on était le permis à points
aurait duré six jours
ci alors des dizaines de routiers
déboule sur le site il n'y a pas de chef
et boutonnet chef c'est mon chef non non
c'est c'est des journalistes qu'ils
aient qu'ils ont trouvé que j'avais une
bonne tête que je parlais bien de quoi
je parlais bien à façon de dire je parle
à tout le monde comme je cachais rien de
ce que j'avais à dire et alors ils sont
fâchés sur moi et puis voilà ils sont
venus aux renseignements par huawei
voilà tout ça il y avait de quoi être
fière 135 est osé mais je faisais ça il
est ok
qu'est ce qui est rouge les boucles
d'oreilles sap a changé et vous devenez
une star des médias
habashi
d'argent tout le monde s'en souvient
oui d'ailleurs 18 ans après oui je suis
encore étonné moi à l'époque ya pas un
journal télévisé qui s'ouvre son qu'on
vous voit vous vos revendications
enfin un permis poids lourds distinct du
permis voiture c'est ce que vous voulez
absolument roulé en boule rouler à
double perdu sur fil infractions rang
poids lourds qu'on retire un point sur
le permis poids lourds et le vl comme
les autres usagers sa part eu lieu parce
que vous respectez
limitation de vitesse etc c'était pas
possible qu'on a déjà vous faisait
quatorze heures par jour donc
pratiquement les ondes et respecté par
un nom en c'est une façon de vous tuer
oui mais faux faux faux faux bien vivre
alors donc ça continue toujours
d'ailleurs bon la situation empire le
blocage dure 200 camions face aux crs
aussi extraordinaire si les crs il n'ose
pas donné l'assaut parce que donner la
sociologue raffinage il y avait des
pleins matières dangereuses
sur un super etc tholot et le polonais
jelen et sert à quoi tout ce qu'il fait
et sauter un rapport
alors voilà vous êtes une star quoi un
jour on vous amène pour négocier avec la
mise et transport vous demandez des
sirènes
oui c'est
aussi bien sur wii cette énergie les
renseignements généraux alors je vais
demander à voir la syrie d'avoir le le
pare soleil avec police tout après tout
ouais hein tant qu'à faire pourquoi s'en
priver pour rencontrer le premier
ministre à l'époque oui pierre bérégovoy
qui comme vous et d'origine modeste
absolument raison de plus pour
s'entendre bien et on s'est bien entendu
c'est grâce à lui qu'on avait 12 points
sur le permis qui n'en a pas alors quand
vous allez voir le le premier ministre
bérégovoy un blazer vert pomme des
sentiers tout neuf enfin jamais détient
que j'avais un pantalon un t-shirt et
une veste
orange aurait fait 4 go s'est pas enlevé
mes boucles d'oreilles pour 80 ans il
est plus un
hélas vous devenez un habitué des
plateaux télé là oui absolument en fait
des talk-shows êtes reçus
vous êtes immortalisé dans une bande
dessinée c'est vrai et j'ai même eu le
un portrait fait par daniel bruel le
sculpteur gars sculpté mitterrand et ses
terres etc
vous enregistrez un 45t war oui mais ça
n'a pas marché mais bon hein c'était
comment bon c'était pas mal donc c'était
beau à oublier un oublié les paroles
otis et mange bitume c'était assez tendu
par les sur une musique ouais ben je
vous prends sortir du tout mais c'était
pas mal pour l'époque
savez-vous marché peut-être d'un côté
rap un peu oui mais rap routier
l'apprenti et là vous avez inventé le
rap à outils et j'ai inventé le rap
routine vous êtes devenus célèbres assez
rapidement finalement
on m'a fait devenir célèbre
mais bon j'avais une bonne bouille sur
tout ça était quoi les réactions de
votre entourage concept devenu comme ça
très connu ben déjà le c'est lui mon
patron qui me viendrait d'ailleurs à
cause d'erreurs et
royal avait 50 50 pour cent du routier
qui était avec moi à 50% qui étaient
mitigées quoi un peu jaloux de famille
ils ont réagi comme ans quand vous êtes
devenus célèbres comme ça ma famille tu
es content ouais à part l'école
manifeste pas contente non non il y
avait un journaliste chez moi tout ça ça
lui plaisait pas elle voulait rester
dans dans son activité mais bon indice
et son histoire c'est pas la mienne des
vers toi elle se réjouissait pas de vous
voir et télévision toute la journée non
non ça ne regardait plutôt quelque chose
quoi auraient tout à fait
vous allez gagner de l'argent c'était
pas plus on est tous tout ça veut rien
rapporté si
j'écris un livre un livre de chez lattès
que l'argent que j'ai reçu de la teste
sam a complété mon chômage pendant près
de cinq mois en fait j'aurais dû gagner
ouais c'est pas grave pour vous ça a
était quoi le meilleur moment quand vous
avez rencontré bérégovoy oui oui ça
c'est
faut reconnaître que là
des billets déjà des centaines de
journalistes qui vous attendait à la
sortie
des troncs vous saluer les joueurs
poussent à lui feront entre et tout est
cool et à l'huissier qui vous aurez qu
toujours su guen faut pas déconner ça
oui non mais il faut baser son plaisir
sinon c'est sympa
une fois une fois dans sa vie comme ça
non non c'était cool il ya eu des
mauvais moments cet été là le manque de
sommeil sans doute parce qu'on n'aurait
pas beaucoup si on était toujours sur le
qui-vive
s'est altérée par les crs et les
gendarmes puis quand civils y avaient
tout cela à partir de là vous retombez
un petit peu dans l'oubli premièrement
je suis viré après bon je passe des
codes et des concours pour entrer dans
l'hôtel de ville comme chauffeur dans la
fonction publique dans la fonction
publique parce que personne ne voulait
fallait bien fallu bien continuer à
travailler j'avais que 44 ans
et aucun patron qui voulez vous engager
voilà c'est ça les emmerde fouteur de
merde carrément l'empêcheur de tourner
en rond dans un camp y voyez ma tête
c'était terminé vous êtes nostalgique de
cette aventure tarzan boy bien sûr
c'est vraiment me dit quoi bah c'est un
moment que
que j'aurais pas et puis qui va pas se
représenter un peu plus fort pour le
reconnaître non mais c'est bien tu est
rancunier vous en voulez des gens de ce
qui s'est passé à l'époque non non la
rancune ça sert à rien ça c'est la
rancune pour moi ça s'arrête ridicule et
oui on prépare à la communauté
européenne selon vous la personne
finalement oui bien sûr pas qu'on n'a
pas eu le double permis si
c'était à refaire qu'est-ce que vous ne
referiez pas pareil
ce n'était pas prémédité alors donc je
crois que je recommencerai pas réglés
comme attention à la retraite je sais
pas peut-être manifester pour les
retraités on essaie presse quelques
années devant moi c'est à vous de rendre
ça pourquoi pas oui ça va ton frère si
on juge une demande oui la bosnie pour
une nouvelle aventure
pour la retrouver pour les retraités oui
il le mérite après tout quand vous serez
mort questionné qu'on écrive sur votre
tombe
j'aurais pas le ton parce que je me
ferais brûler
c'est mieux en poussière on pourrait
écrire les routiers c'était sympa
pourquoi pas oui
maintenant mois a tendance à changer la
route c'est plus comme avant les appuis
de
c'est plus simple pourquoi n'y a plus de
respect il ya plus d'un an les routiers
n'ont pu respect de l'usager
peut-être me faire me dire mais je pense
voilà il reste peut-être encore des
sympa mais pas trop un d'ailleurs il ya
plus de cuisson 1 derrière les routiers
sont sympas et autant que c'est enlever
s'est décollée nord max meynier way
sympa certes elle merci merci temps
j'étais heureux de rallumer la lumière
sur vous merci beaucoup moi je remercie
aussi et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de nos latitudes abonnez vous y mettez
un peu de bleu